>> Bryan: TO MAKE A
COUPLE RIGHT OFF THE BATTEDG ABN
IS ON IT FOR NEW JERSEY.
PUTS IT BEHIND THE FACEOFF.
PRIMEAU BEATEN BUT GETS SOME
HELP FROM THE IN AND, YOU KNOW,T
TWO DEFENSELAYED SINCE
JANUARY 4th.
HE'S A BIGHE GOAL.
HERE IS A CHANCE FOR MERCER.
AND STOPPED BY PRIMEAU.
MERCER SAME VESEY FOR NEW JERSEA
LAVAL.
ABOUT THE SLOW STARTS FOR THEP T
TEAM.
HE SAYS WE'RE AWARE OF,
FOREHAND BACKHAND AND BATRES.
SPECULATION WILL E.
THROWS IT TOWARD THE NET.
LEHKONEN HITS IT WITH IT'S NOW .
KULAK. GET CREDIT.
ON SECOND LOOK IT DOES APPEAR TO
BE HIS.
MONTREAL AFTER.
ROMANOV WITH THE PUCK.
GET ALL PUCKAMES LAST
NIGHT AND LATE
SECOND GOAL.
A NIFTY PASS.
ITIT TOUGH NIGHT FOR
THEM AND FOR PRIMEAU AND YOU
MENTION THE VIEW POWERED BY
THEM OR THEY'VE LOST GUYS
LOOERSON.
FOR ZACHA HE
TOGETHER.AR GETS TO THE FRONT OF
THE NET PICK IN
THAT DEAL. YEAR, BUT THEN IN NO,
THE WHE